hey welcome to a new project camp update
so we bought a piece of land and are
prototyping another way of living
and we're not really sure how it is
going to go but let's see
so you might have seen in the previous
update that it's still pretty early days
and very basic here
wet socks i mean there isn't that much
infrastructure
so you might wonder like how does it
work how do you cook
wash your clothes shower or even go to
the toilet
so in this update i'm gonna show you the
current basic infrastructure i'm using
it's temporary and it's going to improve
over time but very crucial at the moment
so let's start off by getting some water
the walk is about 20 minutes out from
the land and on the way you find very
welcoming dogs everywhere
i'm new here and this thing cool tripod
no not that tree but this thing
almost now so here we are at the water
tank
it's an old spring from 1904 it's great
to get fresh drinking water
i generally fill it up with this 20
liter jerry gun which happened to fit
perfect in this backpack super nice
because that saves me one very sour arm
then a little fresh up and walk back to
the land
next the toilet let me show you how this
is made
it's very basic like very basic but
every time i use it
i like to think i give a present to the
land that's a poophole
and this is kind of everything there is
currently on the land
yep life is pretty basic
but let me show you some more advanced
infrastructure but for this we need to
have a 40-minute cycle to the nearby
town
and it's been raining quite a lot in
these last days but it's a nice cycle
when it's dry in the sun
so here's the center of the town and
let's start with the most important
thing
internet they got it public wi-fi
and i did not expect this but it's just
really perfect
look at the internet speed here
99 megabytes per second this thing is
just max
this is great to get some work done
upload videos or do meetings
but i would add that today is a very
nice and sunny day this is not always
like this
as you can see it also tends to rain
here
a lot
so when it rains there's this option the
library
and there's really no one here ever i
don't know if it's because of corona or
just
outdated books i mean to be fair it's
kind of cold without heating
but again the internet here is just
great
top speed in the library very efficient
place to work
very peaceful okay next
washing clothes this happens right there
so here's my washing machine
watch
and it does take a bit of waiting but it
does give nice fresh clothes
next up showers and this was quite a
tricky one to find
it took some out of the box thinking but
i found a swimming pool in busy times
so yeah it's not a super busy swimming
pool but it's good
cool that they're still open during
corona and later
afterwards we have a shower there
to rinse off all the chloride it's
actually quite some chloride here in the
water
and then we showered
or very clean and it's really great
having this pool around
especially when you get wet and cold on
the land this bob gives a
proper deep warm clean so yeah i'm
quite happy with these basics
so i was walking around here on the land
and i would say i discovered
quite a big thing but let me show you
guys we have to go up to the rock
onto the pathway here
almost there it's on top of there
i discovered that there's actually
internet here on this rock
high in the land i mean that says quite
a lot of hassle going to for every
little fighter email going to santa con
madao
i actually have some phone reception
here which is
kind of a big upgrade i would say
so this is the new office space
only works when it's not raining but it
has a pretty good view
and this week i actually got a pretty
cool new thing it
is the map of this land because we never
really had the latest official map
so up until now we've seen the borders
of the land mainly by just walking
around with the neighbors and the owner
and they say where it is
but here we now officially have to
document
where the borders are i would say this
is still a bit abstract because you
can't really put in perspective
so i put it on top of a satellite map so
it's a bit
better to see where it really goes
this would have also been very handy
while i was making the pathways
to see where the route would go but one
interesting part
is this one uh because some neighbors
said this was
their land but on the map officially it
says it's our land
so i think we still need to figure that
one out
and now i also started drawing the map
here on
a google map so an interactive one so we
can really browse around
more and see the borders of the land so
here you see the work space and there
the kitchen
were very tiny compared to the size of
the land
so yeah that's what we're doing now here
in the office okay so you must think wow
dave that's a lot of big upgrades i mean
you have internet
uh you know the borders of your land
because you have a map
but uh no no that's not the big upgrade
the biggest upgrade
i made by far is this one
yeah yeah you saw that right rubber
boots
all right so that was this update all
the infrastructure currently being used
plus a few upgrades
uh if you want to see all the updates
we're going to do make sure to subscribe
for all the stuff that's coming in the
future
if you want to see the previous updates
of what we did so far make sure to watch
here
and if you like this project i want to
make sure we can continue development
make sure to visit
support.projectcamp.com
thanks for watching and see you next
time